before you watch this video understand
that I know that you know that I know
that YouTube is a corporation and they
have the right to boot or censor whoever
they want but that still doesn't change
the fact that than a bunch of fascist
this is why we created we launched the
mug Club in partnership with CR T V
you'll see now it's more important than
ever it's actually necessity for what we
do because of people who are beholden to
unfortunately the colluding corporate
overlords so there's a lot of news out
there regarding YouTube right now with
advertisers pulling from YouTube and
YouTube changing their whole revenue
model naturally a lot of people are
scared and want some answers to question
so let me explain this to you let's
unpack at first from where this started
before we get into the current revenue
issue and and that's why I like we said
we have to create other streams of
revenue we have the website we have the
podcast the mug club is the most
important thing it allows us to grow and
employ everybody let's get into the soft
types of silencing of voices of
opposition that have occurred on YouTube
for a while and that's been before this
so for example restricted mode this is
something a lot of people don't know
restricted mode is a mode that's I think
automatic if you are not over 18 on
YouTube and unless you are logged into
YouTube and over the age of 18 and
confirm that you can't see videos that
are barred in restricted mode most
people who use YouTube are not active
YouTube users so if you actually look at
yours truly our channel in restricted
mode you can't see anything you cannot
find any videos by the way it's
important note this show is FCC
compliant because that's how this this
show is it was a radio show was a
syndicated radio show before we went
exclusively online so you could run this
show on any radio station you could run
it on any television network that's why
we put the bleeps in there because
that's what we had to do is it offensive
to some people sure is it an actual
violation of FCC guidelines no it's not
now contrast our channel in restricted
mode with with the commanders of using
the word [ __ ] so you know it's real talk
in chief The Young Turks look at this
everything shows up you could hit load
more for David just more for Dave and
their Lackey
Kyle kolinsky there is totally available
these shows are far more profane they'd
be in our rating in a film or an amateur
viewership on television
no restrictions there something even
more important this is like we talked
about earlier with the education the
industrial educational establishment you
know where we where Bernie Sanders wants
us to funnel more money to these schools
without choice put our channel and
restricted mode we have students sending
us this all the time so Young Turks
available in colleges where chanc simply
says our channel we have we list our
references and sources for example in a
15-minute video as to why democratic
socialism doesn't work or the history of
single-payer health care system things
that are actually informative not
allowed on college campus and by the or
high schools yes actually seen Prager
University videos which was some of the
most benign and YouTube now we're doing
this to try and paint a picture where
it's not just well you said some naughty
things no even conservative videos that
are effective that don't say naughty
things are restricted and then leftist
videos that do say all the naughty words
and all the nasty things and all the
hate speech I can't use that that phrase
when ironically sorry coming don't do it
doesn't happen to them now we get to the
point of of revenue so YouTube has
constantly been trying for those who
don't understand this I know it sounds a
little bit technical for people who
understand YouTube has been constantly
changing their algorithms as far as who
gets revenue they invite original
content creators under their platform
people like us created YouTube and they
would give us a revenue split of the
advertising they keep trying to change
it because YouTube isn't profitable and
so it went to percentage of videos
viewed and then it went to overall time
viewed now why is that because YouTube
in trying to appeal to big corporate
sponsors like like a you know Comcast
NBC Verizon Verizon has a channel
there's a channel
they'd sponsored what seriously
something that just literally the social
justice Channel it's all fitness of is
the worse things you hate about social
video that's what an ironic it's like
you flip on us like yep fat glasses
feminists talking about patriarchy
thanks for rise and I just hear you now
and so in order to try to appeal to them
they say well look they go we need most
amount of time watching your videos well
what does that do that means people
upload a video maybe once a week maybe a
couple times a week original content
creators they got pushed out because
they don't have the ability to compete
with say CNN or MSNBC who put out 20
videos a day or the Young Turks and that
why we've been putting out videos
consistently every day you know behind
the pay while they get the full show a
lot of credit com
slash mug clip and then we put up clips
on YouTube so that we're consistent
we're pretty fortunate and that we're
able to compete on that playing field
but a lot of youtubers aren't so here's
what happened with our revenue recently
if you look at this chart we deleted the
numbers for to try and be a discrete
look at that plummets down to zero
overnight and our watch time is over
eight minutes in this channel if you
actually look at the podcast it's 35 to
40 minutes so it's it's changed because
if somebody was there two or three
minutes we've done everything right we
don't have any hard copyright strikes on
our channel we don't actually violate
fair use we don't do clickbait people
come to our videos they watch the videos
for a long amount of time and they watch
our videos more than for example the
Young Turks or CNN or Late Night with
Seth Meyers organically and YouTube
still wants to try and force people like
us out that's the thing if you look at a
YouTube trending homepage now and this
is what's crazy you can find like Late
Night with Seth Meyers or Samantha be
homepage YouTube trending for days and
it has a couple hundred thousand play
yeah
something else we we noticed a big
reason for a revenue drop certain videos
were demonetized on our channel so let's
give them all our videos on Islam nearly
all our videos regarding Islam or do you
monetized okay let's just assume you
don't believe in a form of ideas or
criticizing an ideology you think that
any kind of negative speech of Islam
should be banned because they're liberal
and that's what they want to do it's at
least consistent with their worldview
fine let's give you that but something
else we noticed almost every single
video we have critical of The Young
Turks has been demonetized now if you
want to talk about hate speech which is
it which is a silly term that doesn't
mean anything is putting on a wig and
doing an impression of The Young Turks
again FCC compliant and that it's
bleeped out doing an impression of The
Young Turks in a sketch that could be
seen in any late-night program is that
really a violation of hate speech on
YouTube is that really something so
offensive that you think advertisers
would want to pull and by the way if
advertisers would want a poll guess who
would want to advertise on there all
kinds of channels all kinds of companies
who don't want to be on The Young Turks
channel like the NRA you think Smith &
Wesson you think Ruger do you think
chick-fil-a they want to advertise on on
on leftist channels no there's an equal
and opposite reaction but you
you've often blocks out those sponsors
every single video almost every single
video about the Young Turks that we
offer up critically has been demonetised
this is proof positive that YouTube it's
not about hate speech it's not really
about offensive speech it's not about
racism it is about protecting their
corporate buddies and people who have
the same that's not only financial
interest but but opinion of interests
and lying to you about it because
they're saying no no this is just about
racism it's just about hate speech it's
not it's not they're censoring anything
it's negative from the enters I don't
know if chanc is making phone calls I
know the guy's pissed I know the guy
doesn't like us I know in his show he'll
call it every single gray-haired
conservative Tom Dick and Harry not
named steven crowder he's terrified to
come on this show you know what I know
it I don't know if he's personally
making calls but I do know if you look
at YouTube in their relationship with
the Young Turks politican might as well
be called a Young Turks Khan it's always
check debating someone and Jimmy Dory or
ana kasparian moderating it every single
year YouTube studios I think in Venice
from Marina del Rey they devoted an
entire set to the Young Turks they vet
everything on black YouTube at the Young
Turks were going to be their news agency
and they're still featuring their
content and pushing it and people don't
want it and so now they're de monetizing
other people who are filling in the
market by saying you know actually you
know what you even teasing the uh that's
hate speech so we can't allow it and
that's why you know listen it started
out we saw these storm clouds coming we
created them up we partnered up with CR
TVC of Mark Levin Michelle milk and
myself Matt kibbe other libertarians and
conservatives there it's less than less
than six dollars a month if you joint
you don't have to but what it does do a
lot of people are saying well why don't
you just upload your videos somewhere
else what we do we upload our videos to
multiple points but nowhere else
actually pays YouTube invited content
creators on because they wanted our
business because they were making money
off of advertising and then they switch
the game no other place allows for
advertising so we can upload it if you
want free content we'll always upload
here to YouTube bookmark it check back
but it doesn't pay the bills and
something we've always been concerned
with doing at this shows we just don't
want to yell into a chemical but
feminists twelve people are employed we
want to elevate online content it's
great that people can sit there and
[ __ ] about things into a webcam but
we're actually changing lives we have
researchers we have writers we have
video producers people here are working
on the show are trying to create online
con
to a level of quality that we know you
want and you demand and we've offered it
for free for a long time and a good
portion of it is still for free but we
can't continue to do it so long as
people like YouTube and Facebook and
Twitter keep changing the game that's
why we have the Mudd Club if you guys
actually want to see this content
continue to go on continue to grow the
free content we appreciate if you join
at ladder with credit com slash mug club
but it really is unreal it really is
Orwellian they have their they have the
right to do whatever they want to do as
far as a core being a corporation but
they're lying about it and switching the
game so often thanks so much for
watching I hit the subscribe button or
if you want to join the mug club if
you're student veteran or military it's
$69 for the year to support this content
it'll always be free here on YouTube
will probably be uploading elsewhere but
thanks to everyone who's been with us
through thick and thin and hopefully the
show will go on that's both a figure of
speech and quite literal in this case
click the button click the button I dare
you do it